♪
Yeah, you can see that, uh,
something just came down
through here,
all this lichen's
all rubbed off.
Could be, probably more than
likely an old slide,
maybe a bear come down
through here.
Never know. Not seeing
any tracks or signs.
So I don't think anything's real
fresh, but they are using this.
It is hunting season,
we have a very long deer season
on the island,
which is a blessing.
We don't have moose
on this island,
we don't have really anything
else besides black-tail deer.
Earlier in the spring I did see
a lot of game trails and tracks,
and it looks like it could be
at some time very profitable.
♪
(game call squeaks)
(squeak)
♪
I know this call works good
for, for bear, for sure.
Um, in the spring when
the fawns are dropping,
you can tighten these bands
and make a fawn call,
and then bears will beeline
right for you.
They'll run you smooth over
looking for that fawn.
It's, uh...
So, so far it's worked on bears.
Hopefully she'll get,
we'll get a deer in here.
We do have a predator issue
on this island.
In the spring, those black bear,
when the fawns start dropping,
their only thing
is eating fawns.
And the wolves, their only thing
is eating these black-tail deer.
Our deer population
is dwindling.
It really hammers our chance
to feed our family
when the predator population
is so high
that you're not seeing the deer.
♪
Wind's really kicking up.
I see these conked-up
hemlocks here,
means they're really rotten
and they're starting
to rock and roll.
♪
You got to watch, too, grabbing
these little rotten ones.
You shake 'em
and that top just wobbles.
Sucker will come off there
and whack you right in the bean.
When I first came up logging,
a buddy of mine,
he was cutting, and you can see
there's a rotten limb
that had already
broke off there.
And right above that
big sweeper, it comes out,
he was cutting on it
and started pounding ledges.
Well, it was rotten
like that bottom one,
and that whole sweeper come off
and crushed him.
Killed him, killed him on site.
♪
I do miss logging
and I do miss cutting.
But it is nice to know
every day I'm home with the kids
and I'm not coming home
in a box either.
Happens to a lot of us.
♪